good evening from southern ukraine where
it's been a busy day here it started
with a major trilateral meeting in the
western city of la viv between the
ukrainian president vladimir zelensky
the united nations secretary general
antonio guterres and the turkish
president type richard erdogan
top of the agenda was the fate of
europe's largest nuclear power plant at
zapposia the ukraines have accused the
russians are bombing it and the russians
have accused the ukrainians of shelling
it here first is my report tonight on
the diplomacy of today
the fate of the zaparisia nuclear power
plant is becoming increasingly urgent
this video posted on social media today
appears to show russian military
vehicles inside the plant
the us government accuses russia of
using it as a nuclear shield
a full-on reactor explosion is said to
be unlikely but a radiation leak could
happen if the fighting continues around
it
russia which occupies the plant has
reportedly told workers not to go to the
site tomorrow and delivered this ominous
warning
on august 19th kiev's regime is
preparing a resonant provocation of the
zaparisian nuclear power plant during
the general secretary antonio guterres
visit to ukraine as a result of which
russia will be accused of creating a
man-made catastrophe at this power plant
the zaparisia power plant is the largest
nuclear power plant in europe
it sits on the banks of the dinipro
river and is currently at the centre of
the southern front lines
ukraine blames russia for recent attacks
on the power plant and wants the site to
become a demilitarized zone
the u.n secretary general who met
president zielinski in ukraine today
supports that proposal
the turkish president tayyip richard
berdawan was also in ukraine today he
met president zielinski face to face for
the first time since the war
russia started immediately and without
conditions withdraw its troops from the
zaparisia nuclear power plants territory
and stop all provocations and certainly
all shelling we can't allow russia to
deliberately put us all on the edge of a
radiation catastrophe
turkey successfully brokered the grain
deal between russia and ukraine and
erdogan has met vladimir putin twice in
recent weeks
he seems to have the ear of the russian
president
it's not clear whether erdogan was
carrying a message from putin or if his
comments in ukraine today represent the
current mindset of the russian leader
but the very talk of a peace deal on the
face of it sounds encouraging
the ukrainian government has been
adamant it will not accept anything less
than a full withdrawal of russian forces
from all of the country
at this moment in time it's hard to see
russia agreeing to that